♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES FOR PRESIDENT ON THE
ROAD THIS WEEK TELLING VOTERS
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS AN
AWFUL COUNTRY.
AMERICA'S INSTITUTIONS ARE BUILT
ON WHITE SUPREMACY, SQUEAK TO
BETO O'ROURKE AT AN EVENT
YESTERDAY.
OF ALL THE LIFE THESE PEOPLE TO
TELL, THERE ARE MANY, THIS IS
THE MOST ABSURD.
IN FACT THE UNITED STATES IS THE
KINDEST, MOST OPEN-MINDED PLACE
ON THE COUNTRY.
THE U.S. HAS DONE MORE FOR OTHER
PEOPLE AND RECEIVE LESS IN
RETURN THAN ANY NATION IN
HISTORY BY FIVE.
AMERICANS LIKE TO HELP.
IT MAKES US FEEL GOOD.
SOME OF OUR DEEPEST SATISFACTION
AS A COUNTRY COMES FROM WATCHING
PENNILESS IMMIGRANTS ARRIVING ON
OUR SHORES, BUY INTO OUR VALUES,
AND THRIVE.
RECALL THE AMERICAN DREAM AND
NOTHING MAKES US PROUDER.
IT WAS IN THAT SPIRIT THAT A
1992, THE UNITED STATES WELCOMED
10-YEAR-OLD ILHAN OMAR AND HER
FAMILY.
OMAR WAS BORN IN SOMALIA, ONE OF
THE WORLD'S POOREST COUNTRIES,
THEN RULED BY MARX'S MILITARY
DICTATORSHIP.
WHEN SHE WAS SIX, SHE AND HER
PARENTS AND SIBLINGS FLED A
SILVERWARE AND RUN UP AT A
REFUGEE CAMP IN KENYA.
THEY SPENT FOUR YEARS UNTIL
AMERICA OFFERED THE FAMILY
ASYLUM HERE AND LET THEM SETTLE
IN MINNEAPOLIS.
OMAR'S FATHER DROVE A TAXI THEN
GOT A JOB AT THE POST OFFICE
WORKING FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
OMAR, MEANWHILE, GREW UP FREE IN
THE WORLD'S RICHEST COUNTRY WITH
ALL THE BOUNTY THAT IMPLIES.
SHE BECAME A CITIZEN, AND WENT
TO WORK FOR STATE UNIVERSITY.
A FEW YEARS LATER SHE BECAME A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, ELECTED BY
VOTERS WHO WERE PROUD TO SEE AN
IMMIGRANT TO SUCCEED.
OMAR IS NOW AT THE AGE OF ONLY
361 OF THE MOST POWERFUL WOMEN
IN AMERICA.
IT'S AN AMAZING STORY, REALLY.
ONLY IN THIS COUNTRY COULD IT
HAVE HAPPENED.
ILHAN OMAR HAS AN AWFUL LOT TO
BE GRATEFUL FOR.
BUT SHE ISN'T GRATEFUL, NOT AT
ALL.
AFTER EVERYTHING AMERICA HAS
DONE FOR OMAR AND FOR HER
FAMILY, SHE HATES THIS COUNTRY
MORE THAN EVER.
IN A RECENT PIECE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ," THE
REPORTER PUT IT THIS WAY, "IN
OMAR'S VERSION, AMERICA ISN'T
THE BIGHEARTED COUNTRY THAT
SAVED HER FROM A BRUTAL WAR AND
OBLIQUE REFUGEE CAMP.
IT WASN'T A MERITOCRACY THAT
HELPED HER ATTEND COLLEGE OR
BOLTED HER INTO CONGRESS.
INSTEAD, IT WAS THE COUNTRY THAT
HAD FAILED TO LIVE UP TO ITS
FOUNDING IDEALS, A PLANE THAT
HAS DISAPPOINTED HER AND SO MANY
IMMIGRANTS, REFUGEES, AND
MINORITIES LIKE HER."
IF ANYTHING, THAT IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
OMAR ISN'T DISAPPOINTED IN
AMERICA.
SHE'S ENRAGED BY IT.
VIRTUALLY EVERY PUBLIC STATEMENT
SHE MAKES ACCUSES AMERICA OF
BIGOTRY AND RACISM.
THIS IS AN AMORAL COUNTRY, SHE
SAYS.
SHE HAS UNDISGUISED CONTEMPT FOR
THE UNITED STATES AND FOR ITS
PEOPLE.
THAT SHOULD IT WERE YOU NOT JUST
BECAUSE OMAR IS A SITTING MEMBER
OF CONGRESS.
ILHAN OMAR IS LIVING PROOF THAT
THE WAY WE PRACTICE IMMIGRATION
HAS BECOME DANGEROUS TO THIS
COUNTRY.
A SYSTEM DESIGNED TO STRENGTHEN
AMERICA IS INSTEAD UNDERMINING
IT.
SOME OF THE VERY PEOPLE WE TRY
HARDEST TO HELP HAVE COME TO
HATE US PASSIONATELY.
MAYBE THAT IS OUR FAULT FOR
ASKING TOO LITTLE OF OUR
IMMIGRANTS.
WE AREN'T SELF-CONFIDENT ENOUGH
TO MAKE THEM ASSIMILATE SO THEY
NEVER FEEL FULLY AMERICAN.
OR MAYBE THE PROBLEM IS DEEPER
THAN THAT.
MAYBE WE ARE IMPORTING PEOPLE
FROM PLACES WHO ARE SIMPLY
ANTITHETICAL TO OURS.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
BUT THERE IS A PROBLEM AND
WHATEVER THAT BECAUSE THIS
CANNOT CONTINUE.
IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE.
NO COUNTRY CAN IMPORT LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO HATE IT
AND EXPECT TO SURVIVE.
THE ROMANS WERE THE LAST TO TRY
THAT WITH PREDICTABLE RESULTS.
SO BE GRATEFUL FOR ILHAN OMAR,
ANNOYING AS SHE IS.